all right hey everybody we have a
very special day today in a few
different ways i'm going to explain to
you exactly how momentarily
part of the reason is that we are
expecting
two live streams today and these are
going to be some of the last
opportunities
to get to a million subscribers before
our vacation because we are going to be
on vacation next week and unfortunately
the way the math is looking right now
and it's just it really is unfortunate
we
are projected to hit a million
subscribers on september 21st
now the thing is that's not really true
because we're at 9.92
we're actually at about 9.93
which is seven away and we're getting 2
000 today
so we're really probably more like three
or four days away which will be during
our vacation but i am
wondering if it's conceivable that by
the end of tonight's stream because
there's a second stream tonight it's in
about four hours
i wonder if we could get to a million
today so we're gonna be going for it
uh we are going to be hearing from
donald trump presumably at the top of
the hour
he might actually be on time today and
the reason i
say that is he actually has
sort of a tight schedule today because
of the second event
he's scheduled to meet with pompeo at 3
30
and then at 3 45 is the out of town pool
call
time um at joint uh base andrews to head
to
where is he going tonight uh michigan
tonight there's this rally in michigan
at seven so he may
actually have to stay on schedule today
to the extent that trump has to stay on
schedule
and we are expecting as you can see here
about
um 80 minutes of remarks from trump
tonight
at another corona rally so we'll have
that later for you two streams today and
then we will be on vacation
next week so hoping for a very very
powerful
situation uh welcome to the 10
000 of you that are already watching
across our three
major platforms youtube twitch and
facebook it's so great to have you here
um i do have
fresh memes i do have fresh memes for
you guys but the only issue is
i'm not going to have fresher memes
tonight so i don't know if i should hold
the memes for tonight or just use
show the same memes twice i'm guessing
the audience tonight might be
maybe a slightly different um audience
than the one that we're going to have
now so i could do the same memes twice
or i could just hold the memes
for tonight welcome to everybody
watching on twitch
um we do we are already almost at a
level 3 hype train on twitch if you're
watching on youtube or facebook
don't even worry about this uh but don't
don't worry about it
but we do have you know broon breed
and not thumb and jarrell chess and all
of these great people
supporting the hype train over on twitch
um
let's see where do i want to go maybe we
will just show some of the memes let me
first do a few super chats
actually no before i even do before i
even do that i have new members to thank
already
robert waltman is new member number one
andrea brown is new member number two
and david
braunlik is new member number three so
we're already
at three new members and i i've
basically
not even started yet okay a few super
chats chakaseki
says do you think today trump will
tender his resignation and we will
finally see the
dissolution of the turd reich the turd
reich i like that
no i don't expect resignation matt
chavez says i've gotten 400 plus
2016 non-voters to commit to voting for
biden in arizona
arizona that's how we beat trump stop
debating his cultists and just get out
the vote yes yes well said
azar says hey david this week our house
was selected
at random to participate in the nielsen
ratings for most
watched show it was easy david pakman
show
by a landslide very powerful i
appreciate that
and dark chip says sam cedar ain't gonna
be happy if you hit a million tonight
speaking of which let me i'm going to
give you guys one element
okay this is
anthony mellen fantano's
1 million uh subscriber congratulations
this is early i'm i'm previewing this
you know it's it i know people want to
imagine like we hit a million
and everybody congratulates obviously
these things take time so we already
have received most of the congratulatory
messages
let's just listen to one okay i'm just
gonna show you guys one
okay okay okay okay well
well mr david pakman
congratulations on one
million subscribers from anthony fantano
right of the needle drop the internet's
busiest music nerd
keep on speaking truth to power
and messing up your hair and stuff
you're the best good job buddy
there you go guys so so a very very
inspirational message a defiant message
from anthony fantano
about fighting the forces that would
seek to keep wait no he didn't say any
of that stuff actually
but it's a nice message a nice message
and of course
um donald trump also recently
uh i don't know if you guys saw that no
hold on a second that's i'm getting
ahead of myself
did you see donald trump's disgusting
tweet saying that this is what joe
biden's america looks like
look at these two that is a scary scary
message
and as you can see this is fake 69
000 retweets 420 000 likes so that's not
real
but it is pretty funny so i'm glad that
i was able to show you guys that
um okay super chats continue to pour in
autumn says do you think the fire
spreading along oregon and california
could be related to trump saying
portland was on fire
no zach foster says david with dr burks
also downplaying the covid threat even
though she knew trump knew it was bad
how is this woman still getting media
appearances i called berks out
i called berks and bricks i called them
both out months ago
and it's uh it's stunning to me stunning
to me
daniel says are trump's frequent
appearances on hannity recently a sign
that he's worried about the election
i believe so i believe so uh ps congrats
about to hit
1 million subscribers yeah
thanks to david and proclifo proclifo
says will trump announce his plans to
pardon snowden
i don't think we're going to hear that
from him today
yeah by the way does anybody know if
anybody uh is live in the room right now
i would love to have a live feed
i always prefer a live feed but i'm not
able to find one right now let's see
trump live
uh is bloomberg live in the room they
might be
bloomberg could be live which would be
beautiful
bloomberg is yes
let's go over to bloomberg very much
immediately
just so we can keep an eye on what's
happening in the room after we see a joe
biden ad
will you vote for joe biden yes i will
okay good all right so now we are we are
in the room and we'll have a sense of
what's going on
okay a church of chris says via super
chat
just under 3 000 watts 3 000 watching
the white house live
10 000 here yeah it's wild what's going
on my youtube rep actually told me that
i don't i may have mentioned this before
on the rnc night we had a bigger
audience than the trump
official youtube channel on some of the
rnc nights if you guys can imagine that
it's insane
um thank you to scuttlebutters and
deflated brady
we have 20 seconds left to achieve a
level 4 hype train on twitch
dead runs thanks for the sub grizz bat
thank you uh and there it is 100
moving on thanks to mukrumpus
moving on to a level 4
hype train um let's see here
the requisite twitch message asking
whether i even look at twitch chat has
just surfaced
it's always i you would imagine it's
almost like i've asked
someone to do it but um somebody
eventually will always ask
yes yes i am looking at twitch chat
um other new members to say thank you to
savannah williams is new member number
four today
ryan saunders is new member number five
aaron cornell
is new member number six okay enough
demands for fresh memes i'm even though
there's a second stream tonight guys
i am going to show you some of the fresh
memes let's see what i've got uh okay
i have um this is a deep fake
of me as trump we had deep fakes
yesterday or two days ago
of me as um iron man
and of me as conor mcgregor i believe is
his name
this is a deep fake of me as trump okay
this is this is pretty aggressive take a
look at this
look at me go
[Music]
so anyway that's nicely done uh like
that one
here is oh okay the other day i posted
this
on my instagram and i assumed it would
be ripe for memification
i thought it would have high mimetic
potential and i got nothing from people
these are some of my prepping
supplies and we finally did get one here
is me
i guess outside the white house holding
a medical plaza
a medical plasma bag as you can see
and um this is sort of like a please
disperse moment
so finally finally a meme related to
this image you can find that on my
instagram
at david.pacman i also have i'm just
going to get all of these out of the way
for you guys as we're waiting for donald
trump
i've also asked many times if your pets
like watching me on tv
send me the video okay this is video i'm
going to present to you today
of drago this is eric's dog
drago and um
this is him i guess he just loves the
david pakman show look at drago locked
in here
but mitt romney is not the center and
that's important to understand
when the left thinks the center is
something that it's not
look at that good boy he tries to appeal
to the center in the wrong ways
so let me know what you think i think
that this new center
represents a lot of the changes we've
been locked in
which would include a sort of status quo
perspective on some issues and not
all right so that's drago eric's dog
very much appreciated
if your pets if your pets like watching
the david pakman show
david i feel like we don't talk enough
about how if trump
loses where is that coming from reading
from the sidelines constantly and i'm
curious your thoughts if you think
i have no idea where that's coming from
so hold them up as a god
if you think um members of congress will
um what the hell
could be influenced by him or if they're
just gonna if they're eager to just
have an excuse to ignore him i'm curious
their thoughts
i realized what happened it went on to
the next file which was the
voicemail for today's show okay i
apologize about that
um okay so we figured that out so anyway
if your pets like the david pakman show
particularly dogs we accept cats but
really we prefer dogs
uh please make sure to send those in
because
we we absolutely love those um
[Music]
i'm trying to get a better feed there's
like uh
there's a mouse cursor going up on top
of the screen here let me see if i can
find another feed for us
here's the hill feed here's the fox
business feed
the bloomberg feed all right we've got
multiple feeds going
so hopefully we're going to be able to
do it all okay that's it as far as memes
for today i don't have anything else for
you
so let me get back to some super chats
here
okay the vegan villainess
set oh by the way we have two and a half
minutes left still
to complete a level five hype train
we've not completed a level five hype
train for about 10 days
so thanks to hannibal and metrobe and
hannibal again and reich
chef and the freak and all of these
great people we we actually
may do it we may be able to do it
the vegan villain s remember when trump
yelled to liberate
certain states that were on lockdown
back in april trump is a murderous
psychopath hashtag
trump knew can't disagree with the word
you're saying vegan
christopher mizel says i subscribed as a
soy boy
greetings from vienna austria you know i
was scheduled last month to go to
vienna and salzburg
um and then then the plague came in
and uh i didn't make it as many of you
know i hope to get there soon i've never
been to vienna
christopher my christophe mizel says
just call me chris it's easier that way
okay chris thank you
white death says whoa where did that go
white death says have you looked into
interviewing any
uyghur activists yes we have we've
reached out to some and hope to schedule
that soon
jacob ratner says if trump wins is
leaving the country an overreaction
depends on your priorities depends on
your priorities i can't tell you what
you should be doing
we have completed a level 5 hype train
over on twitch with one minute to spare
very much appreciate that
just go travel says david i love you
focus so much on the million subscribers
as trump focused on reaching
his his 1 million lies both unnecessary
thank you
thanks to josephine for signing up
rising phoenix says trump saying drank
the kool-aid regarding black people in
the u.s
is especially hurtful the phrase comes
from the people's temple massacre yes i
highly recommend
jeff gwynne's book um about jim jones
and uh it is an excellent excellent book
jeff guin
fantastic author of sort of narrative
disaster nonfiction and i encourage you
to check it out
michigan mama says do you think trump's
inaction on kovid will ruin his chances
at the nobel peace prize
i'm refusing to even acknowledge the
nobel peace prize thing
other than on today's bonus show where
we did acknowledge it but i don't i
don't want to deal too much more with it
jl switzerland has since jl switzerland
says hey david we really trust in your
voting power to reclaim
true democracy a hopeful message from
switzerland a true
direct democracy boy do i miss
switzerland in particular right now i
have had some great times in switzerland
thanks to everybody signing up here by
the way donna erie abigail
uh i have been to zurich i have been to
lugano i have been to the outskirts of
zurich that's really my switzerland
experience i think
what a country really what a what an
amazing place
chakuseki says what do you think trump's
excuse is going to be about his truthful
interview with woodward
that his frontal lobe was turned off
with quaaludes
he's going to say that he didn't say
anything wrong basically he's going to
say listen when i said i didn't want
people to panic
that's a good thing i didn't want people
to panic because i'm a leader
it's not believable of course uh because
with the immigrant caravan exactly what
he wanted was people to panic
with joe biden's america he's trying to
create panic
so he wants panic when it's advantageous
trump has no
moral aversion to panicking the american
people
thanks to jen oh hold on luke says
i think it's only fair you reciprocate
melons gesture
by wearing a yellow flannel on your next
live stream i don't own a yellow flannel
so that'll be tough
fork bomb says happy birthday david
thank you my birthday isn't for months
but i do appreciate it
zesty says you must have to agree with
trump from the standpoint of
sophisticated crowds
biden is clearly a marxist leninist
of course of course
um you have not missed anything donald
trump scheduled to speak at the top of
the hour
we are waiting on the white house feed
by the way
fifteen thousand people watching on my
youtube channel only four thousand
watching on the official white house
feed can you imagine that isn't that
wild um
we are keeping an eye on the bloomberg
feed we are waiting on a feed from the
hill
and we are waiting on a feed from fox
business
so hopefully we will get some of those
going
very very soon um i do
want to warn people we have two streams
today
this one and then one tonight we are now
only 6 700 youtube subscribers from one
million okay
socialblade told me we were not going to
get it for 10 more days
we could get it today we could get it
right now there are
16 000 people watching on youtube right
now
if less than half of you hit the
subscribe button now
we could do a million subscribers right
now otherwise it's likely going to
happen during our vacation next week
unfortunately
but we're going to be pushing very
strongly for it because we've got this
stream tonight trump is having a rally
in um michigan i believe and
we could actually do it today we really
could do it today which would be just
unbelievable
people asking about chess we will be
scheduling another chess tournament soon
now that i'm done with pog
champs um we're going to be doing other
chess things
and i'm i think that some of the people
that taught me
in advance of pog champs will actually
be playing in my tournament which would
be a really great thing
very very much looking forward to it
thanks to
jakku jetty or jedi for the twitch prime
subscription it is september
jakku jedi says keep up the great work
sir
d storm has subscribed deflated brady
is supporting yali marie is supporting
um okay things are getting a little
wacky here
uh fried rice official says david
my dad has starting what started
watching you now
and i want to thank you for being such a
great well that source
in such a weird time cheers mate quite
poggers
is poggers good or bad guys does anybody
know
i hope it's good i think it's like giga
right it's very very big and powerful
it's good it's good okay it's bad oh my
god well then i don't like it
let's see other super chats coming in
uh what happened here i missed some
oh boy carrie says canada loves you all
i want to fish with my friends again yes
to fishing
dominic richardson says live talking
orange embarrasses country
in delusional propaganda rant that is
what the title should be
big sos man says you say you prefer dogs
but you'll love my cat
you know i i do prefer dogs that's true
i do prefer dogs to cats
danny thompson says adding to the vegan
villainess comment remember when trump
wanted everything to open on easter
april 12th
yeah how insane does that seem in
retrospect
it's completely outrageous abigail wardy
says thanks for covering the rnc
listened with you while driving across
the country with my dog
lola there are so many trump signs
across the country thank you for keeping
the progressive push
we are going to keep doing it uh let me
very briefly um i'm going to give you
guys my hard sell membership pitch which
is really a very soft sell
okay here's the bottom line i'm inviting
you to grab a subscription on my website
joinpakman.com
if you don't like me forget about it
don't do it
if you like me but you can't afford two
bucks a month
don't do it the show is here for you the
streams are here it's all here
if you like me and can afford two bucks
a month
and you actually want to support what
we're doing go to joinpakman.com and
grab a membership okay the coupon the
normal prices are a little higher but
because you're my friends
you can use the coupon code 2020 now
which is right above my head
and you'll save 66 percent okay that
makes it
two bucks a month if you pay for the
year it's a dollar eighty
i will try to thank everybody who signs
up to the best of my ability
and it really is our number one funding
source
that discount is so big there are
certain counties
where they have these blue laws these
antiquated places very puritanical
the discount is so big it would be
certainly illegal
and probably immoral in a lot of those
more puritanical parts of the united
states so
check local laws if it's even okay to
accept a discount so big but if it is
um certainly grab a membership at
joinpakman.com i will thank some people
right now
arslan ali arslan ali is new member
number seven
miranda garza is new member number eight
hand reader is new member number nine
nick carrera
is new member number 10. josh franklin
number 11.
linda stravoo number 12.
nikki hajal lucky number 13.
i will get back to that the website is
on fire right now the website is just
there's a hundred people
browsing the website right now
considering memberships
uh let's see how many of those folks
sign up i don't actually
expect trump to be too late today
because he does have a schedule to stick
to
um he has a meeting with mike pompeo at
3 30
and then they're flying out to michigan
not that much later
so i actually do think trump might not
be that late today we'll see
uh it's always any it's anyone's guess
thanks to mutual
wolverpine not wolverine wolverpine
for the twitch prime subscription
aqua5am has subscribed
reggienerd has subscribed on twitch
really appreciate it we did uh we did
peak
at about 14 30 twitch subscribers in
august and of course since it's monthly
a lot of those folks have fallen off but
we are fighting back up as you can see
up in that vertical blue rectangle up to
1183
and my promise to you is
if i have it my way we will get to 1500
by the end of the month that's my goal
and i do think that with the
presidential debate towards the end of
the month which i will be carrying very
very proudly
um we actually have a shot at getting to
1500 on twitch
which would be uh very very interesting
okay
other super chats coming in chris says
i'm
born in salzburg countryside is pretty
as hell yeah i've never been to austria
salzburg very high on my list chris i
hope to be able to make it
once uh once things normalize
i uh i really don't know how else to say
it but once things normalize i hope to
make it to austria
ryan saunders says good evening david
watching from yorkshire uk
thank you for all you are doing and
wishing all americans good luck in the
election stay safe thank you
green randy says p is stored in the
heart that's a weird mess that's off
color i don't like that
david gora says thanks for helping me
get through the day with your streams
thank you david for supporting our work
stephen says david are you offended if i
refer to you as daddy
i am i do find that very very much
offensive
keith jacobs says microsoft just warned
china
hacking biden campaign haven't seen that
but i will look it up chris says my
fantasy football name is i got
plasma congratulations on 1 million
listen let's do something special
because across
our various platforms we are over 20
000 live concurrent viewers right now i
am going to give you guys
my favorite song of the summer today i'm
pleased to
make a truly historic announcement this
is joseph woodward's masterpiece
plasma battle against the china virus
that will
save countless lives
right
[Music]
to help treat patients battling
[Music]
incontinence
[Music]
listen that's better than anything i've
seen from justin bieber right
i mean let's uh let's be perfectly frank
there um i
am planning to record my own drum track
to that song
i am having some tech issues with my uh
maybe somebody in the audience can help
me
i um uh i have the roland td-9
v-drums and i am just having a hell of a
time
getting set up properly to put the track
so i can hear it and record a master
track with the drums
i've got five or six different
iterations of cables
and i just like cannot get it done it's
just not i've not
got it set up correctly if somebody
knows exactly what i need
please let me know please let me know
okay
um someone just told me that they have
delayed this press briefing
until 3 30 which seems like why maybe
caitlyn collins is leaving
and uh i believe this is mario from
bloomberg
who is heading out let's actually look
at the official schedule
and see if it indeed has been
rescheduled
not on trump's official calendar but
that doesn't mean it hasn't been
rescheduled it certainly could have been
um let's look at
oh maybe maybe trump's twitter would
tell us a little something about it
um he did now say it's going to be at 3
30. okay so we have 25 minutes remaining
wow
wow wow wow uh okay well that's all
right
maybe i will um what should we do as far
as that goes
yeah and that see i have some boxes
right outside
let's um yeah okay i'm gonna brown
myself
out just briefly and then i'll be back
and then we will pick it right back up
because i do have some boxes sitting
outside and a couple things if i don't
deal with
we will be screwed so i'm gonna be right
back uh
very very powerfully and very very soon
hold on
all right everybody i'm back had quite a
situation going on here at my place
they have rescheduled the press briefing
from 3 p.m which was about 20 minutes
ago
to 3 30 p.m which probably means it'll
start in two hours the way these things
tend to go
trump actually needs to leave and go
where we are going to be covering
his rally later which is going to be in
uh michigan
and i think he's on an actual tight
schedule so who knows but
i think they are going to be um
hopefully close to 3 30 although at 3 30
again per donald trump's schedule
scheduled to meet with mike pompeo let's
refresh and see if it's been updated
no update all right so we don't know
what's going on but we are going to
stand by and see what goes on
um later today um the corona rally
in michigan certainly expected to have
no masks
no social distancing and could become
another one of these
super spreader events i don't know if
you guys heard but the
sturgis motorcycle rally in south
carolina is believed to have caused 250
000 cases that doesn't mean it was
so only 400 000 people went only
the it's not that 250 000 of those four
hundred thousand got the virus
it's some smaller number got it went
back to their home states
spread it those people spread it those
people spread it and if you estimate a
one percent death rate
that means that the sturgis motorcycle
rally
arguably responsible for about 250
deaths
if it is responsible for 250 000 cases
um no i'm sorry uh 2500 deaths what am i
talking about
my that would be 0.1 percent um that's
pretty ugly stuff
that's pretty ugly stuff if i say so
myself okay
we've got um
what is happening there's a lot of crazy
did the chat get out of control while i
was gone it seems like while
while i was gone um
a lot of people got banned that's ugly
that's i'm sorry to hear that
let's get to some of the super chats
that are coming in but before i do that
thanks to no lad for the twitch prime
sub judge judy x
mav pew pew yogiende
has subscribed pink and blonde has
subscribed
megawatt has subscribed as well people
asking about spanish language content
i we do have a spanish language
interview that i did last week
which i'm in the middle of uh subtitling
i didn't realize how much work it was
going to be it's a 40-minute interview
in spanish on a puerto rican podcast
i thought i'll just do the translation
myself so people will know what's going
on
um i'm like 20 of the way in and i'm
already like more than an hour into the
translation it is a much slower process
than i thought but i've committed to it
my friends
i've committed to it so i am going to
try to get it done in time for uh for
our vacation next week
um okay let's see here eddie awesomes
says hey david do you think trump will
do something desperate to gain positive
press
like push for a fix to daca since
majority of people support it
now i i don't expect trump to do
anything immigration related
uh between now and um between now and
the election i don't
dare ten says would you be interested in
speaking at british universities
yes sure uh i'll go wherever they pay me
by all means i've actually got some
remote
college appearances coming up that are
being scheduled now
and i think that they will be very
interesting i am insisting i am
demanding
in the interest of free speech and
transparency
that if a college wants to pay me to do
a talk
and they want it to be private so like
20 um
students can participate that's fine but
i always ask here here we go now
i ask that the video be made available
to me so then i can publish it to
youtube
that's that's my thing that's i always
ask for that
okay uh chris says could you send could
send a pic later
via your facebook page chris i don't
know if you mean a picture of the
austrian countryside
uh or what but that is interesting
thanks to philip for signing up
sean says run up the vote concerned
canadian
yes run it up run it up
i see dead llamas says all of this news
is wearing down on me
mentally but i feel responsible if i
don't stay informed i feel trapped and
really want this election to end
yeah we're planning like a four-year
vacation after this election is done
depending on the results right
you know what i'm talking about okay i
i've fallen i've fallen way behind
on new member thank yous so let let me
try to do some
okay because i know people are getting
mad marietta birdo
is new member number 14.
deborah modi is new member number 15.
joanne lin is number 16. george rennie
is number 17. aaron thompson 18.
um okay i'm getting double subscriptions
for some people i think that's wrong
frank oliveri is number 19
and brian miller brian miller
is number 20. i know that there are a
few more and i i will get to those doing
the best i can
oh also becky gurley has made a patreon
pledge and we're counting those so becky
you are number 21.
i appreciate that very much up two
streams today yeah so if you're just
joining us
okay two streams today this one
this is a stream and we will have a
stream
scheduled to start at about 6
40 p.m eastern time just 20 minutes
before the start of donald trump's rally
in michigan this evening i am going to
be pushing for a million subscribers
today
okay i know that you know if you do
something like going over and looking at
socialblade
it says that we're not going to hit a
million until september 21st that's ten
days from now
okay rough ten ten and a half days from
now i believe we could actually hit it
today
we are only 5600 away right now we are
only 5600 away
so between today's street this afternoon
stream
and tomorrow stream i'm sorry to night
stream i actually think we could get to
1 million subscribers today
which would be absolutely insane now
if we don't do it we are on vacation all
of next week and it starts to become
very likely that we will hit
a million um while we're on vacation
which is a little bit anticlimactic i
guess we'll come back and we'll have a
million subscribers on youtube but
it seems it seems cooler to do it during
a stream
quite frankly i don't know but you know
it'll ultimately be up to you guys
thanks to earl and klaus for the youtube
subscriptions
richard oh boy where'd that go hold on i
missed a bunch here
oh boy we just lost a whole bunch of
these super chats hold on
um oh my god i there's where are they
so many of these super chats came in i
can't even find them oh here we go
okay richard says a toast to
outnumbering
el flatule's channel sir i don't know
what on earth that is
does anybody know what that is i don't
know what that is
thanks to mindy jusko travel has
retracted a message
kevin's grabbed a subscription mike says
i have no confidence trump will provide
any new information during this
confidence
during this conference you are likely
correct
you are likely correct thanks to alan
scuzzle but says pog means play of the
game oh i didn't know that
i did not know that that's interesting
auntie fa
that's clever trump didn't want to panic
americans
trump wanted to cheerlead and watch
americans get sick
wow wow
jane woman power says my dear friends
here love and respect david and his
amazing work
hit that subscribe button big love from
canada
you know we earlier in the stream when i
mentioned this goal of a million
a thousand people subscribed in like a
minute it was
nuts sam cedar's furious furious right
now bolo says damn it david you're just
so
damn good at what you do damn thanks
bolo
uh thanks to boomer and earl sabine
boomer plus jonathan storvick says
recent subscriber really enjoy your
election coverage david thank you
you know i was thinking maybe we'll
stream on election night maybe we won't
i don't know i mean it's like i might be
busy that night who knows
that's a joke by the way that's a joke
obviously we are going to have a huge
stream on election night
what i'm actually starting to think
about is
do i want to pull in
additional uh hosts
for election night so we could go like
from me
to someone else to someone so do we want
like a rotating cast that we could go to
it's an interesting idea it's an
interesting idea for election night
so we're going to be looking at that um
and i don't know exactly who they would
be i know that there are favorites in
the audience and people that
those in the audience don't like um
but we'll think about it we'll think
about it if you have an idea people
rushing back into the room now so
presumably donald trump will be starting
soon
let's see if the white house feed has
gone live it has
so we're going to go volume up there
we're going to keep all of these other
feeds
going but silenced because we only need
one
set of audio we don't need trump audio
and triplicate that would be horrible
um okay other new members
amit kapoor is new member number 22.
matthew brooker is number 23 j.c
bennell is number 24 or bunnel
nancy hardy is number 25 david hale
number 26
craig geiss number 27 and as you know
when we get to 25
i always say let's go for 50. let's try
it
let's try it i think we can do it james
montalbano says how should trump square
i don't want people to panic with
antifa is coming to take your property
and seduce your women fear-mongering
exactly the right question there's
kaylee mckennany and scott atlas who
favors a
herd immunity approach to coronavirus
which could lead to 1.5 million deaths
or even 2 million deaths 2.2 million
here is donald trump
let's see what we've got today
thank you very much wow we have some
big ones today this is a room loaded up
wow paula reed jonathan carl
phil rucker hi phil how are you
kate it's bill rucker we've got the
all-stars a lot of all-stars today
youtube you too oh my god this is good
well that's fine
this is a weird start thank you very
much in the past
four months we've added 10.6 million
jobs after losing
643 manufacturing jobs and
600 it's already a live fest they've
recovered
some of the 50 million jobs that were
lost stations we've experienced the
smallest contraction
a contraction of any western nation
meaning
we've been affected less than any other
nation
western nation and probably almost i
think you can put us in
i just saw some numbers i think you can
put us into just about any category
anywhere
no and the fastest recovery by far and
that's anywhere
nobody's recovered like we're recovering
none of that's true if we followed
joe biden's strategy we'd shut down the
entire country after just having
set records on growth trump both brags
about how it was the right
decision to shut it down when he did it
and criticizes biden
over something biden didn't actually say
he would do an economic crisis in our
history
by contrast the obama biden
administration had the slowest weakest
and worst recovery in american history
we continue to make progress in our
fight against the china virus
new weekly cases have declined by 44
percent
since july death state line
last week he said they were down 80
percent but then it didn't go so well
these numbers are not really meaningless
out of con they're not really meaningful
out of context the european union which
have recently experienced a sharp
increase in cases
they're having a very big spike over
there we're we're hopefully
beyond our spike and we'll see but we're
doing very well all over our country
in the past five weeks per capita cases
doubled in france
surged to over 300 in spain
which i've been hearing about and
speaking to
some of the leaders of spain and he
doesn't even get the numbers he doesn't
understand stats
and increased more than 400 percent in
italy again
and as you remember i stopped i put a
ban on people coming in from
europe remember that when your numbers
are tiny
saying a 400 increase may not really
mean that much i know you guys know that
we we also put a ban on europe
so spain is uh being heavily impacted
france and
400 percent in italy yesterday european
nations experienced 50
more deaths than the united states
and you don't hear these things you
don't hear these statistics but the
united states has done really well
i'm proud of everybody that worked on
this we have the ninth highest deaths
per capita in the world if you don't
include
san marino and andorra if you do then
we're 11th highest in the world
not discussing therapeutics we're
rounding the corner
we already have therapeutics out there
by the way which are having obviously a
very big impact because you look at that
you look at the the way people are
recovering
so much better than in the past before
we knew about the disease and had
anything to fight the disease
on schools as part of our science-based
approach
we want schools to safely
open and stay open children are
extremely low risk
of complications from the virus less
than 0.2 percent
back to this huh 0.2 percent of
the coronavirus deaths have occurred and
those
under the age of 25 and most had
underlying conditions where there was a
problem
there's no substitute for in-person
learning according to a recent study
student progress
in math decreased by half
half and using online education compared
to
in-person or campus education so online
we think of
so many things online and how great it
is there's nothing like being in the
classroom that's what we've learned from
this whole
ordeal according to the cdc
school closures disproportionately harm
low income and
minority children as well as those with
disabilities
and i think you see some slides behind
me that are
very uh new very current
i believe trump i mean he's not just you
know led us astray before i'm sure he's
telling us the truth about everything
we hope that they do indeed stay open we
want to see big ten football we hope
it's coming back we have a lot of the
uh colleges that we're talking about
they want to come back we hope that
michigan agrees we hope that and i know
the governor will have a lot to say
about it we hope she
might look at this slide we have a
couple that maryland's another one
we hope the governor puts a little
pressure on so that we can have it but
i have a feeling they may do it they may
do it without
having everybody but i think they're
going to have maybe
michigan maybe maryland we have a couple
of of
states that might not participate
but people are working very very hard to
get big ten football back and i'm
this is like everything you shouldn't do
in a slide country and uh
the players and the coaches want to do
it really badly the
players are missing they only have so
many years of this and the players are
missing a big opportunity
including the chance in some of the
cases they have some of the best players
college players in our country and they
want to get into the nfl and they want
to make money in the nfl and they're not
going to be able to do that too easy if
you don't get to see you should open all
school football programs for colleges
because three to five players might get
to the nfl
uh the alternative it's the alternative
is no good
then going home spreading the virus to
high-risk americans it's
they want to be on campus they want to
go back to school and the parents want
them back in school maybe
more so than they want to be back in
school and they want to back safely and
they want to go back safely but they
have to go back based on
the recent data from more than 20
colleges not a single student who tested
positive for the virus has been
hospitalized
so that's a lot of people that's a lot
of students not one
has been hospitalized as we continue to
follow the science-based
approach to protect our people and
vanquish
the virus joe biden continues to use the
pandemic
for political gain every time i see him
he starts talking about their pandemic
he's reading the norfolk teleprompter
right the so voters say the pandemic is
the most important issue
and so it's logical that biden would
talk about it 200 000 people have died
yes i don't know i think if i did that
i'd be in big trouble
i think that would be that would be the
story of the year
when i took early action in january to
ban the travel
and all travel to and from china
the democrats and biden in particular
called it
xenophobic you remember that joe was
willing to sacrifice american lives to
placate the radical left
open border extremists and
nobody's calling for open borders who
has any position of power in the
democratic party nobody
saved millions of lives by uh doing the
closing and now the opening the way we
did it
joe's decision to publicly attack the
china band proved he lacks the
character or intelligence or instinct to
do what is
that projection that is projection
biden's launched a public campaign
against the vaccine which is so bad
because we have some vaccines coming
that are incredible so they're trying to
frame biden and harris as anti-vaxxer
trump's the guy who tweeted about some
kid who got autism from a vaccine
trump's the guy who had to be talked off
alleged by ben
what's that guy's name ben carson during
the debates when trump went anti-vaxx
trump is arguably
the actual anti-vaxx president and now
they're trying to frame harris saying
i don't take trump's word as being
anti-vaxx it's sick
we're starting to see they're incredible
actually
[Music]
biden's perfectly happy to endanger the
lives of
other people by doing something that he
thinks is going to help him politically
because his polls are getting very bad
they're getting very shaky
polls this was an election that was
going to be very easy very quick and
then the china virus came in and
i had to go back to work politically
unfortunately had to devote more time
politically than what a victim
i mean guys okay sure 200 000 americans
died but
he was going to have an easy re-election
until the virus hit come on
looks like we're going up very rapidly
more rapidly than the media wants to
admit and biden's had to go out he's
gotten out of his basement and he's
working let's see what happens but we've
got to talk about how great these
vaccines are if in fact they're great
and i think you're going to see numbers
that are going to be very very
impressive
strong numbers the
approach to the virus is a very
unscientific blanket locked down by the
democrats that's what they're talking
about
which takes all of these incredible
statistics records
by the way no one's talking about a
blanket lockdown anymore who like
who is actually saying now everything
must close over nobody's saying that
he's fighting against a straw man we did
the shutdown
and now we're doing the opening and
there won't be any more shutdowns
there could be a little section a small
section we have a breakout but we're not
talking about shutdowns like that's
exactly what democrats are talking about
about depending on experts we're not
going to be doing that
the swine flu was a disaster
you remember when remember biden and
obama had
66 percent approval on swine flu and was
vice president
his failed approach to the swine flu
was disastrous he called it he called it
n1h1 it's actually h1n1 you know you
remember the h comes before the
end so it's sort of easy to remember
right but joe right always calls it the
opposite way but it was
call it the swine flu it was disastrous
and his own chief of staff said that
when biden helped
manage the swine flu in 2009
they quote did everything possible
wrong and 60 million americans got
h1n1 in that period of time there's a
quote from his chief of staff
and it's just purely you guys i'm sure
you guys remember how h1n1
was actually like the flu i remember
my brother got it and they said you know
we don't even really need to test
because
it it is essentially the flu i mean it's
just it has nothing to do with this
situation telling us
a manner he can't manage himself 270
000 americans were hospitalized during
this attack the outbreak was so rampant
that the obama administration
told states to stop testing we don't
want any tests exactly
you didn't need to test because there
was no additional information that
testing provided it is a dramatically
different situation
once it was widespread and we realized
the treatment is just the same as flu
there was no reason to test because it
made no difference the reason
we were trying to test early was to
actually control the spread
it's just it's like a little kid stop
counting tests
and stop counting cases oh my god and
then left us
a depleted stockpile which is what i
inherited i inherited a depleted
a very badly depleted stockpile in other
words but yeah he only had three years
during which he could have replenished
it before the virus had of this very
serious
highly highly contagious epidemic or
pandemic the china virus countless more
americans would have died
and if we didn't do what we did and i
say it all the time now because
the media likes to belittle what we've
done has been incredible now you can
look at europe and you can look at other
places and you can start comparing
it's ugly biden is weak on china
yesterday was revealed that
a fund partly owned by joe biden's son
hunter
facilitated the sale of a michigan auto
parts producer to a leading chinese
military defense contractor
you don't want to write about that do
you biden spend his entire career
selling michigan jobs to china
literally enough now the biden family is
selling out our
country directly to the chinese military
which has to do with his company that
hunter here we go with hunter again he
didn't have a job now all of a sudden
he's selling
companies from michigan to china china's
military got american manufacturing jobs
and
the biden there's a lot of stuff that
could hurt biden i don't think
this unhinged rorschach test of an
attack on hunter is going to do anything
for trump
america he will they will own america
finally i can announce with great pride
that secretary of state mike pompeo will
be
departing this evening on a historic
trip to duha
qatar for the beginning intra afghan
peace negotiations we've been
negotiating with them for quite some
time
going to doohan getting along with them
moved a lot of soldiers out
i got a report this morning that there's
been nobody
killed in afghanistan since early
february
it's a long time there's been no deaths
no problems
and a lot of progress is being made in
afghanistan but
we'll be down to 4 000 soldiers in a
very short period of time likewise iraq
will be down to about 2 000 soldiers in
a very short period of time
and in syria for the most part we're out
other than we kept the oil
as we have soldiers guarding the oil
arguably
a small number but they're guarding the
oil
and we're helping the kurds and we're
making their lives
much more pleasant because of the fact
that we have the oil
so we're pretty much out of syria
we're pretty much out of iraq and we're
down to the smallest force
that we've had in uh we'll be very
shortly down to that number
in afghanistan the negotiations are a
result of a bold diplomatic effort
one part of my administration in recent
months and years the united states will
play an important role in bringing the
parties together
to end the decades-long war it's been
going on for almost 20 years
long before i got involved i can tell
you that
don't blame me and had they not been
wasting our time with all of the
phony witch hunts and all of the things
we probably could have done this even
faster
but a lot of time had to be spent wasted
like that
but the parties are together right now
and we're
negotiating and we're really making
tremendous progress
next week at the white house we'll be
having a signing between
uae and israel and we could have another
country added into that and i will tell
you countries
want to go into it uh as you know uh
uae is headed by a very very highly
respected
gentleman and respected by everybody
and he's a warrior too he's a great
warrior
and muhammad is very excited about this
and you'll be hearing other countries
coming in over
a relatively short period of time and
you could have peace in the middle east
i think what ultimately will happen is
you're going to have
quite a few countries come in the big
ones are going to be coming in i spoke
to the king of saudi arabia so we're
talking we're starting
we just started the dialogue and
you'll have them come in and i think two
things are going to happen iran will
if we win the election iran will come
and sign a
deal with us why would iran sign a deal
with him
when he just canceled a deal that they
stuck to this is
maybe the worst the least trustworthy
negotiating partner
iran could imagine a number and they'd
like to be able to
get back to having a successful country
again
so i think that'll happen and i think
very importantly
the palestinians will get back into
the fold and when they see all of these
countries that frankly have been
supporters of the palestinians very big
supporters and certainly financial
supporters
as you know we used to pay the
palestinians 750
million dollars a year and i ended that
some time ago on the basis that they
didn't seem to want to make peace
and we'll think about it once
we have a deal but i've ended that quite
a while ago
i'm frankly surprised they haven't been
to the table
earlier but this is the best way this is
a way that's going to be great this can
really bring the middle east to
what is this guy talking about since
february we haven't had a death in
afghanistan which is
that's a record for many years not a
death
and we're getting along very very well
with the taliban and
afghanistan and its representatives and
we'll see how it all goes it's a
negotiation but
secretary of state mike pompeo will be
let's get to the questions
in a little while so i think that's very
exciting news
and a lot of people thought that my
natural instinct is war no my natural
instinct is
actually peace when we were on the
devils his natural instinct is
how can he try to make himself look
better how can his narcissism
be fed like a bottomless pit
military that two and a half trillion
dollars new jets and rockets and
tanks and ships and a lot of things we
have we have
the newest best military we've ever had
so
hopefully we won't have to use it our
nuclear program has been put into gear
like never before and in particular
hopefully
we won't have to use that because that's
a whole new level
of destruction and we never want to just
have to pray to god we never have to use
that right trump's a praying man
yes thank you mr president why did you
lie to the american people and why
should we trust what you have to say
that's a terrible
question and the phraseology
what i said is we have to be calm we
can't be panicked
uh i knew that the tapes were
these were a series of phone calls that
we had mostly phone calls phone calls
and uh bob woodward is somebody that
i respect just hearing the name for many
many years
not knowing too much about his work not
caring about his work but i thought
it would be interesting to talk to him
you have to throw in a period of
you know calls so we did that i don't
know if it's good or bad i don't even
know if the book is good or bad
but uh certainly if uh he thought that
was a bad statement
he would have reported it because he
thinks that you know
you don't want to have anybody that is
going to suffer medically because
of some fact and he didn't report it
because he didn't think it was bad
nobody thought it was that's not why
woodward didn't report it although there
is controversy over that and i talk
about that on tomorrow's show
television network it's a disgrace to
your employer
and that's the answer are you ready
because you think
i i love you of course i didn't of
course i didn't
know that in the flu and then you went
out and told the american public
that this was just like the flu
here we go five times do you ever hear
the expression five times we've had a
few years where we lost a hundred
thousand people
he's gonna explode the flu is a very
serious problem for this country also
and we've been losing them scott what
kind of a number have we lost over the
years with fluz into the hundreds of
thousands
if you combine a whole bunch of years
last five years have been something like
35 to 80 thousand per year
every year even with antiviral drugs
flu is a very serious problem also but
just saying this is worse than the most
friendly
deadlier than the most strenuous flu
okay and then you went out and said it's
just like the flu
right what i went out and said is very
simple listen
what i went out and said is very simple
listen i want to show
a level of confidence and i want to show
strength as a leader and i want to show
that our country is going to be fine one
way or the other
whether we lose one person we shouldn't
lose any because this shouldn't have
happened this is china's fault this is
nobody's fault but china china should
not have allowed it to happen
whether you have a one person 180 000
people
or two and a half or three million
people which it could have been
every death is tragic but the idea that
it's the same no matter how many people
die is an idiotic idea
put the ban on dr fauci said we saved
hundreds of thousands of lives by
putting the ban on china and then
ultimately putting the ban on
europe there was no lie here what we're
doing is we're leading and leading in a
proper way
and if frankly somebody else was leading
it they wouldn't have closed it
if you look at nancy pelosi i hope every
reporter asks a question about this and
calls him a liar like jonathan carl did
months later they said there's no
problem they're talking about me
months later and before any statement
was made you have to remember i put the
ban on china
so obviously outwardly i said it's a
very serious
problem and it's always a serious
problem that doesn't mean i'm going to
jump up and down in the air and start
saying people are going to die people
are going to die no
no i'm not going to do that we're going
to get through this and we're right now
i hope
really think we're gonna we're rounding
the final turn
and a lot of good things are happening
with vaccines and with therapeutics
but there's no lying and the way you ask
that question is very disgraceful
go ahead yeah
i think we did a great job and the
people that did such are generals or
admirals
mike pence or the generals he called
[ __ ] in recordings with bob woodward
right and now dr
atlas dr fauci
burks they should be respected for the
job they've done
so you won't die you won't downplay it
again because you said you downplayed it
that's what you told me all i'm doing is
no i don't want to jump up and down and
start screaming death
death because that's not what it's about
we have to lead a country we're leading
a great country
and we're doing a great job and the
people that have done such a good job
should be given the kind of credit that
they deserve we possibly have done the
best jobs
when you start looking at what we're
doing with the vaccines and therapeutics
and ventilators
we had no ventilators john the best job
ventilators now a month
and we're supplying them to the whole
world the job we've done is the best job
and don't give me any credit give the
people that have done this the credit
they've done a great job yeah phil go
ahead yeah mr president you talked about
the need to stay calm and not just up it
down and and scare people a lot of other
world leaders
were called german chancellor angela
merkel was very calm as she presented
information to the german people
beautiful that they could stay safe and
protect their families
so why is you as president of the united
states did you not level with the
american people did you not share the
information
that you knew at the time in real life i
don't know what what angel is doing but
if you look at the european union right
now
they're having breakouts so he says he
doesn't know what angel is doing but
throughout this entire thing he would
talk about how angela is calling him for
help and all of this other stuff and he
seemed to know exactly what she was
doing
much much better than the european union
i just read your numbers that are
not good on their behalf that are very
good at ours and we have rounded the
final turn
and we have we're going to have vaccines
very soon maybe
much sooner than you think listen maybe
much sooner than you think
but we have done a phenomenal job and
the people that have done this job
including the american public that's how
to put up with a lot
with the lockdowns and all of the things
that they had to do they have to be
given credit
they have to be given credit virus you
knew it was airborne
you knew on february 7th you told bob
woodward how it transferred from person
to person
in the air how deadly it was why did you
not come to the podium
well let me ask you this if bob woodward
thought that was bad because this is
stuff that everyone knew
there's a report that i have here
someplace
where china said it was airborne earlier
than so the reason woodward didn't go
public unfortunately
is because when trump agreed to the
interviews when it's an interview for a
book that's going to be out in months
it's either explicit or implicit we'd
have to find out that
the the material doesn't get published
piecemeal before the book
that's almost certainly the answer to
that question the fact is
there has to be a calmness you don't
want me jumping up and down screaming
there's going to be great death there's
going to
and really causing some very very
serious problems for the country
if bob woodward thought here we go what
i said was bad
then he should have immediately right
after i said it
gone out to the authorities so they can
prepare and let them know
but he didn't why would it be bob
woodward's responsibility to get
authorities prepared
but does that make any sense one that
said it was bad or thinks it was bad
were
the fake news media because they take it
and they try and put it a certain way
if bob woodward thought it was bad
then he should have immediately gone out
he thought it was bad and he didn't
immediately go out
it's maybe five months he's had it for a
long time it was a series of taped
interviews
mostly by telephone quick ones not long
ones quick ones
and it was i did it out of curiosity
because i do have respect and i want to
see
i wonder whether or not somebody like
that can write good i don't think he can
but let's see what happens right
thank you mr president um we're just
about 50 days out from the election and
we haven't seen a lot out of the durham
investigation yet
yeah where is that and do you do you
have confidence in the investigation oh
my goodness well i can't tell you that
yet i have to see i'm not involved in it
is that oan state uninvolved i'm
i guess considered the chief law
enforcement officer
of the country i could be involved if i
wanted to i thought it would be
better if i wasn't i think it's better
if
our great attorney general handle it he
has durham who is a
very very respected man and we're going
to see what it is i can't tell you that
i can tell you this i can tell you this
they
uh they lied they
cheated they leaked
they got caught they started my campaign
never in history has there been anything
like this and i guarantee if the roles
were reversed
never in history has there been anything
like this people would have been in jail
at the very highest level people would
have been in jail for
two years already nothing like this has
ever happened and the term would be for
many many years
because it's treason and other words can
be used also
do you think there should be more
indictments as a part of this well i
think just on what i read in your
wonderful papers i think
and and see what you know just looking
at the media
not even what i know uh i think comey is
a disgrace to
our country i think strzok who just
wrote a book
which is a total fake is a disgrace i
think paige
lisa page his lover is a disgrace to our
country
i think that when you look at mccabe
where his wife got 700 000
they should all be in prison plus obama
and biden according to this guy
right and then hillary clinton is under
investigation and yet she paid the head
of the fbi
one of the top people but actually the
head because he took over for
for the other guy who fortunately i
fired i made a good move when i fired
that was a smart move
because they were looking to take down
about this administration
duly elected administration so i fired
him
it was a great move when i fired him
because maybe if i didn't i wouldn't be
here talking to you as president
but when mccabe's wife gets seven
hundred thousand dollars in campaign
imagine thinking that this is
fundamentally about andrew mccabe's wife
virginia and yet he's in charge of the
investigation of hillary clinton now he
says well i wasn't really in judge of
course he was a judge
he was totally in charge he knew exactly
what was going on these people got
caught
in the probably the biggest political
scandal in the history of our country
the biggest political crime
now what the durham report is going to
say i can't tell you
but if they say half as much as i
already know just from
seeing it you know you have people i
watch some of the
shows i watch liz mcdonald she's
fantastic i watched
fox business uh i watched
lou dobbs last night oh god blue dobbs
yesterday said that yesterday was one of
the best days of trump's presidency
i watched fox and friends in the morning
you watch these shows
you don't have to uh oh
uh oh details they cover things that are
it's really an amazing thing they got
caught
in the biggest political scandal in the
history of our country
they were spying on their opponents
campaign
not only spying they were making up fake
dossiers you have the
dirty dossier they were making up the
dirty
it was all made up it was all fiction it
turned out to be fiction
and then they were using that in the
fisa courts imagine seeing a transcript
of this answer
not so revered anymore courts i like
because when you look at what they did
and how they played it and they heard a
lot of people
general flynn is still being hurt and
he's being hurt very badly
he's a wonderful person i spoke to
general milley about general flynn two
weeks ago i said what do you think of
general flynn he said
he's a great soldier sir he's a
wonderful wonderful human being he's
been destroyed
he's been it seems mostly trump just
watches tv that
this uh without knowing anything about
what durham is going to release the
durham report we'll call it
uh or maybe it's going to be more than a
report maybe it's going to be much more
than a report i don't know maybe it's a
report or maybe it's much more than that
right but when i look at the uh he's not
going to walk out after this right after
taking two real questions and then this
fake one
yourselves back and forth i think it's a
disgrace to our country and i think if
people
don't pay a very very substantial price
it'll happen again and this should never
ever happen to another president
thank you very much oh my god i called
it two
questions from actual journalists which
are about his obvious lies
one question from oan and then he just
bails oh my god it i
actually what you know it's weird when i
started
saying he's not going to walk out after
this is he
the first half of the sentence i was
joking
and something about his demeanor by the
time i got to the end of the sentence
made it seem like he
actually may be rapping at that that is
unbelievable
unbelievable listen thank you to the 30
000 people who joined me for this
perfect live stream
i want to get to a million youtube
subscribers today
we're only 5 000 away there's 26 000
people watching right now
okay we could get to a million
subscribers
right now we could do it uh according to
socialblade
we are still about 10 days away
i think we could actually do it today so
on your way out we have a second stream
tonight of trump's corona rally
to be notified hit the subscribe button
on the way out
and you'll help us this says we're 6 000
away we're really 5300 away it's
actually a much smaller margin
uh help us out let's do it let's do it
so we can move on and get beyond
it and then we're going to move on to 50
000 on twitch and then we're going to
move on to a hundred thousand on twitch
and we're gonna go to iowa and we're
gonna go to new hampshire and you guys
know you guys know how it works um
all right let's play us out with the
plasma song i will be back in just about
three and a half hours with you fine
folks
um with the trump corona rally
completely to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
convalescent flows from strong
antibodies
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat
[Music]
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million to fund the mayo
clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescent
[Music]
convalescence
convalescent